what is going on everybody and welcome
back to another JavaScript basics
tutorial in this tutorial we're gonna be
talking about the four loops in
JavaScript we're gonna cover the for
each loop as well as the regular old
bland boring for loop so with that let's
get into it
so where we left off we created this
blob object the blue object if you will
and we showed how we can kind of work
with it and manipulate it in the console
but we still have yet to have seen why
you know syntax was saying hey these are
going to be so much better than using
functions and just scripting up a bunch
of blobs this will be better I promise
now I'm going to show you why because of
how easily we can create new blobs and
get them to do things on the canvas so
to start I'm gonna get rid of this line
and I'm gonna copy and paste this line
that ends in a semicolon I swear we'll
copy that we will paste paste
I didn't mean to paste for but that's
okay we'll do all four we'll do one two
and three there we will do red we'll do
blue here and we'll make this one orange
so now we've created these four
different blob objects now I'm sure some
true programmers are crying that we've
done it this way and don't worry we'll
fix this in a little bit with another
for loop but for now we're gonna keep it
this way
and then what we're gonna do is we want
to add these to some sort of container
and the container that we're gonna use
is an array so we're going to go up to
the very top and we're gonna just create
a new array that will house the blobs
for us so I'm going to say let and we're
gonna call this blobs and that's going
to be equal to a new array object
semicolon and then now what we can do is
we can keep pushing the blob objects
into an array so an array is like a list
it's just in this case an array can take
on many different shapes but in our case
we're just going to have it be a one
dimension
and just contain the blob objects so
coming on down here we want to add these
blobs to the array now the way that we
do that the syntax to do that is simply
to say blobs 'don't push and we want to
push the thing that we want to that
array so in this case new blob and then
we're just gonna do that with the other
three so to do and then one two three I
just realized that I said one I guess
this could be we could call it zero
because we're programmers and we meant
to start at zero that was the plan the
whole time so now now blobs has this
blobs array has four total blob objects
within it now then next thing that we
want to do is let's just create a
function and we're gonna call this
canvas draw and this function is going
to draw to the canvas these four blobs
but the first thing we're going to do
before we do any actual drawing is we
need to clear the canvas so what we want
to say is context dot clear rect and
don't forget context is in reference way
up to the top of this canvas dot get
context 2d that's what that's in
reference to so context clear rect and
we clear from zero comma zero and we
clear all the way to canvas daunt
width to canvas daunt height awesome
semicolon now once we've done the clear
rect now we want to draw all of the
blobs that we know about now the for
each loop is super useful for this we
could we could use a for loop here but
I'm going to use a for each loop and the
way that we're gonna do that is
basically you're gonna say the object
that you want to iterate over now
obviously this object needs to be
iterable so in this case blobs is the
array that has four blobs but we're
going to say blobs dot for each and
we want to do this thing now in this
case the thing that we want to do is a
couple of things
so instead because every time we draw a
blob we actually want to move the blob
now we could in theory if that was
always gonna be true rather than having
the draw like every time we draw we
could at the end of draw run a move like
every time we drew it but later like we
that might not be something we want to
do every single time we draw it like
maybe the blob holds still for some
reason so we don't necessarily want that
so that's why in this case you don't
always have to you know do a for each
and then run some sort of function but
in our case that's what we want to do so
we're gonna say function and then the
parameter to this function will be just
object now this could be anything it
could be blob we're just giving a
temporary name to each of the elements
in blobs so each element in the blobs is
a blob object so you can call it blob
you call obj you could call it this like
it really doesn't matter I'm gonna say
just object because that's what we're
iterating over objects and then like all
functions we've got the curly braces and
here we do the code that we want to do
so we've referred to every object as obj
so then we would say obj dot draw and
then we want to run an object dot move
after we've drawn it because we do in
this case one all of our blobs to move
around so there's canvas draw now
finally we just need to set interval
this canvas draw so set interval and in
this case like our for each our interval
is actually just going to be a function
and in this case it's just an empty
function but all we're gonna say is can
well actually we don't have this time we
actually could just pass all we want to
do is canvas draw we don't want if we
don't really need to anything else so
that should be fine so actually we can
do canvas draw every 10 milliseconds
semicolon so so cool let's run it see
what
it's not updating um let me think about
this set interval the thing we want to
do and then update it every 10 seconds
why wouldn't that work I would expect
that to work and surely it wouldn't know
okay news to me Ike
my entire use case of set interval has
always been passing a function but I
guess in this case and that starts to
make a little more sense why it was why
it made those functions that you loaded
local so when you do a set interval I
guess it just pulls in this and then
runs it interesting cool like I said how
much you have to scrutiny I don't know
why you guys are still watching
so anyways cool so now we've got that
working and we did it with the for each
loop which I think makes a lot of sense
like a lot of times you're just going to
simply you're going to be iterating over
an iterable and doing things with the
things as you iterate over it so for
each just makes a whole lot of sense
I really like that now the next thing we
want to do is rather than making blobs
this way this is kind of a terrible way
to do it so instead we can use another
for loop and make our blobs now the way
I want to do that is with your typical
boring bland for loop and the way these
work is it's for some you know condition
we do a thing okay so it's like an if
statement almost now the thing that we
want to do is we're going to just simply
blobs dot push and we're going to push a
new blob object and in this case for now
we'll fix this soon but we'll just pass
green and then 25 okay and then I'm
gonna delete all of this so mm so in
this case we just need to setup the you
know parameters for this for loop and
the way that we're going to do that is
we're gonna say let I is equal to 0 so
the first parameter just says okay we're
starting I is zero
then we're saying I less than five this
means while I is less than five we're
gonna run this for loop and then the
third thing that we're gonna pass here
is I plus plus so every time this four
loop runs we're gonna add one two I and
effectively all this is doing is running
this loop five times so if I go up to
the tippity-top here and I specify a new
constant and I'm gonna say Const a blob
count equals ten let's say now I can
take blob count come down here and rat
and just replace five with that and then
now we're gonna get ten green blobs and
now that we've done that we only have to
change it in that one location and the
for loop handles the rest and then the
for each loop handles the rest so like
with functions you would have to like
copy and paste in like three different
locations it would be stupid so so now
let's go ahead and run this make sure it
works as intended beautiful so we got
all these green Bluffs pantsing around
okay so the next thing is they're all
green we want to make them a little more
colorful so I'm going to come up to the
top and what we're gonna say is Const
colors equals a new array object
semicolon and in this case we are going
to have just just we're just gonna write
out some colors here so we're gonna say
red orange yellow chute green blue
purple o matic colors black pink all
right great
pink pink cool that's enough so okay so
now we've got colors and then what we
want to do is actually just pick a
random color now I could be wrong but
from my very short internet research I
did not see and like just a random
choice option
for JavaScript so instead the way we
pick a random thing is a little hinky
but that's okay so I'm gonna come into
our for loop and I'm gonna say let and
then we're gonna say let random color is
gonna be equal to and we're gonna say
colors and then we're gonna grab an
index and all we want to do is grab a
random index from colors in order to
grab a random color and the way that
we're gonna do that is we're gonna say
math dot floor basically this just
always rounds down so we're gonna say
math dot floor of math dot random open
and close parentheses don't forget those
times colors dot length so what is
actually happening here let me just
scroll out and then I'll highlight okay
so all we're again all we're trying to
do is just get a random index that way
because our true goal is just pick a
random color and here we're saying math
dot random x colors length it's
basically the exact same logic that we
were using to pick a random starting
point on our x and y-axes so all we're
doing is we're just figuring out which
we're just going to hopefully grab a
somewhat pseudo random index of colors
and again math that floor because we
want to round down if we allowed it to
round up there's going to be times where
the index will just be out of range
there won't be such an index and we
don't want to deal with that so now
we've got random color so now we can
take random color and throw it into blob
and then we can run that and now we can
see we've got a nice assortment of
beautiful colors of blobs bouncing
around and now let me think here so the
next thing is week so we could make this
all one line and just throw it into
there but in my opinion this is quite
ugly if I'm reading through someone's
code real quick and I get to this line I
got a look at it for a second I was like
okay math at floor and it's a random
times the length okay it's a
and I'm sure if you've been programming
JavaScript for a while and you see this
line it's like a probably a really
common one if especially if I'm correct
in my assumption that there's no such
thing as random just like like with a
lot of languages you just boom random
and it just picks a random and it's
really simple so in this case probably
what I would do is make another function
and I would say random choice array okay
and then in here I would just basically
copy this and then replace colors with
array so this and then or R and since we
haven't returned anything with a
function boom that's how you get a value
from a function you just say return so
here we're gonna return a random choice
from random choice so now let random
color can actually just be a random
choice of colors semicolon
okay so now let's go ahead and run that
and see if I screwed anything up because
it probably did nope not very good
random though a hence the pseudo random
but it works nonetheless cool all right
so that's pretty much it the only other
thing I just don't like and I just
really want to fix is the balls are
still kind of bouncing around uniformly
so to fix that I would just come up to
where we define the x and y change and
make that math dot random cuz that's a
that's gonna be a random number between
0 & 1 so so it seems pretty fitting you
could just toss in math dot random there
and then we can rerun that and that
should be a little more yeah like a
little more random where the balls like
clearly aren't following a similar
trajectory everywhere the other thing
you could do is like every time you hit
a wall you could reset things so like
every time you hit a wall you could
so before you flip that number get the
current number mmm I guess you would
just reset the current number and then
flip it but you'd have to know if it was
plus or minus anyway maybe we'll add
that later but yeah you could do that
too like every time it hits a wall or
something but we're kind of getting
beyond the scope of pry where I want to
take this tutorial anyways in terms of
getting that right instead I'd like to
do other things like getting input from
the user and stuff like that so I think
that's what I'm gonna focus on in the
next tutorial honestly haven't even made
the next tutorial so I don't know for
sure but anyways if you're enjoying this
content but a boom bada bing you can hit
that beautiful blue join button to
support the channel very much
appreciated just went over about a
hundred channel members that's awesome
so anyway that's all for now questions
comments concerns suggestions whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
I will see you guys in another video